i always thought the combination of you
and mike together
i thought it was a perfect pairing
musically like i hear radio like music
and you know i think he should have
fought very very hard to keep you
as part of his team the two of you
together
made life easier for one another i
totally agree and i've had them on twice
you know
on did you i've had them on recently a
lot here on our show
very sharp you're right there is a
chemistry there
and you have that perfect grouping
that's like a perfect harmony you know
we know how to play off one another and
when
mike needs to be uplifted i can screen
and when mike and we need this
calm down mike can bring us down that
was a great team it's a great radio team
and i'm fascinated by radio teams that
break up you know
i value my radio team i think mike
and and i don't know the guy so you can
correct me but i don't think he valued
you enough
i really do not think he valued union
enough
uh i think there's a lot to that i i
think there is a hundred percent
i do think mike understands now after
all this time
that the team was a super team so i i do
think that now
i do think you know mike's not going to
come out he's just not going to come out
and
you know do accolades on chris russo
this is not much not mike's way
so you're not going to hear mike for an
hour and say you know what a partner
what a show yes it's not mike's deal
that's not the way he is so from that
standpoint you're not going to get him
to admit it
but i do think you're right i do think
that what we had as a team
was very significant that's why me
leaving trying here
was was a hard decision to make mike
francesca has been honored by the radio
hall of fame
you were 50 of that i mean why have you
not
been inducted into the radio hall of
fame and do you care about it
first off the fact that i'm not inducted
and i have you to talk about it because
i know you talk about this
it's almost better if i don't get in
because i have you
i have you out there so i have you
support me that's the first thing
but three years ago it bothered the hell
out of me did you ever contact i don't
know even though
who would be in charge of that no
contact no no contact
if you were gonna honor that show with a
hall of fame
you'd have to honor both guys um i
shouldn't tell you this
because you're not gonna you're gonna be
you may not like it
but i i have a dream that if
i did get that honor and you know you
got to have somebody
do a little speech for you that's right
you know you know i'm going to ask to do
it don't you
you now i dream that you never ever get
into the
radio hall of fame would you do it would
you do it if i asked you
you wouldn't i'll tell you you would say
chris uh thanks the offer but i'm gonna
pass
here's the truth i have been so critical
of that organization
i would feel hypocritical to show up
and you know induct you into something i
don't even
i the fact that you have to be voted on
is offensive to me
you know who would be fabulous to induct
you into the radio hall of fame
and i mean this david letterman you know
what howard
that is why you're brilliant that is
perfect you're right i would ask him
i think he would do it for you i do i
but now you must miss that show and i'll
tell you why
it that was the glory days you're a
hundred percent right
that was a very very significant part of
my life with him
twice in a row in 2003 i
had a book out and dave invited me you
know dave was going to promote the book
as you know he was good with that as you
know
and the first time i went in there you
know i took a day off you know how it is
you got to leave the show early taped at
5 30.
one day i go in there and he's got demi
moore on
so i get bumped come back about a week
or whatever was maybe a couple weeks
later and courtney love is in there
right and i get bumped again i think
nothing of it this is david letterman
this is part of the world
you have to understand this about a week
or so later
i'm driving to work this is when i was
on fan
i'm driving to work local station in new
york and i get a phone call
and it's dave they say chris hi david
letterman
hey yeah you know it's 10 o'clock in the
morning hey what's up
it says i want to apologize for
bumping you twice unforgivable on my
part
and if you would do me a favor and you
know
forgive me and next time we have young
would you come on and i said david you
crazy of course i come on
from that moment on he always gave me
two segments
not one a local little radio guy from
new york who's no big deal
under any circumstances this is not
serious now this is on fan
calls me up on the way to work and says
chris i apologize
you have to apologize he's david
letterman because chris
dave knows how difficult it is to do
radio he respects radio guys he's done
it himself and he knows how difficult it
is to hold an audience he respected you
that's why he picked up the phone i was
really impressed by that i was really
impressed by that that
he did that and you know it's it's guys
like
you know listen you and dave i mean when
you think about it in my era
a little past carson i mean you you two
you're the biggest media guys out there
but i miss dave i miss dave listen i'm
not stupid
eventually they're going to put me in
the radio hall of fame i mean i hate to
say that it sounds cocky
but eventually they're going to they're
going to run out of people hey you know
how about russo that's throwing a bunch
of one of these days you think they'll
go through
everybody in radio and then they'll
finally get to you yeah say you know all
right you know he's 81 years old
but now that i know that you would
rather not be asked you you gave me an
idea
i will i will go to dave